let's get to your second one which is
you know the saints defensive
coordinator and dennis allen who has had
tom brady's number he's eaten his lunch
now multiple times what has it been four
out of five matchups that he's gotten
him only the playoff one is the only
game that tom brady has won against the
saints and basically brady's bullied
every other defensive coordinator except
dennis allen so what does he know about
tom brady that these other guys don't
well he knows the exact same game plan
that i tell you if you got if you have
the personnel you got those big guys up
front and i told you this in the
pre-game show you can rattle tom brady i
played with tom i played against tom
i've seen it i covered him basically 13
years of his career and if you put that
inside pressure on tom he gets nervous
and if you hit him you make him
uncomfortable in a pocket he's going to
hold the ball but the second part to it
and i thought they did a great job look
at look at the tight man-to-man coverage
look at the tight man-to-man covers what
they say tom brady releases 2.5 seconds
he can't do that because the coverage
the rush those guys are making a move
around chauncey gardner-johnson that's
another guy i want to talk to you about
now you talking about jaylen ramsey
that's that's a cheat that's that's
jalen ramsey about 18 million dollars
cheaper okay that's who he is he is an
absolute football player he can play any
position he brings him energy he makes
plays he sacks the quarterback he can i
mean he does it all you see he's not
intimidated he's telling tom brady we
here we're here to kick your butt they
stepped up man dennis allen
this guy should be considered at four
head coach no question about it his
defenses have been great he's a steady
type of personality he's a good guy
he definitely deserves consideration
i i'm not going to say that the bucks
would have won this game if they still
had some of their guys right as soon as
as soon as you have no godwin and now
you have no mike evans you're already
without antonio brown now there's no
lender for that i mean they basically
didn't have a chance at that point and
brady's out there with a bunch of guys
who
probably more than anything he's played
with lesser receivers over his career we
talked about that on sunday but just to
have the reps in the chemistry with
these guys he wasted all those reps on
the guys who were out of the game and
hurt but i mean for them to lose a game
at home where all they have to do is
score more than nine i mean tom brady
hasn't been shut out in 15 years and i
think the reason is and give dennis
allen a ton of credit just because he's
done it over and over again but
not not very many defenses can rush the
passer across the board with davenport
with tuttle with david onyamata with cam
jordan who missed the prior week so i
had fresh legs coming back and he looked
fresh the way he was flying around that
football field but they also have five
great cover guys to have the combination
of the rush and the cover players i
can't think of another defense that is
as dominant on both ends of the spectrum
that's just a hard combination to find
and brady took it right on the chin
and you forgot about mentioning
linebackers demario davis is a top five
middle linebacker he is absolutely
fantastic we talked about him he can hit
he can tackle he can cover he can blitz
he can do it all and kwon alexander like
quan alexander he was a first round
draft choice and he didn't work out for
san francisco and he kind of bounced
around but it seems like he's found a
home you know in new orleans he he looks
like his old self like athletic fast
making plays celebrating so he's brought
him a lot of energy and a lot of juice
as well
that's a great point cause i remember
kwon alexander covered gronk and how
many times you see gronk run that route
he runs it right to the linebacker and
he turns around and breaks right back to
the sideline and when he tried to break
back the silence kwon was all over him
he was running to the sideline before
gronk even decided that he was going to
go that direction so you got to give
credit to all these guys and demario
davis man even when i was watching the
week eight game demario davis was going
screen to the right the whole defense
was running to the right before the play
so yes he has all the physical tools but
probably more than anything his mental
and leadership stuff that just lining up
the defensive backs talking and lining
up the defensive front he appears to me
to be the leader of that entire defense
and you see what what they're producing
imagine if the saints had a quarterback
man if it weren't taysom hill we'd be
talking about a potential super bowl
team here
brother i was just sitting here thinking
the same thing i'm like how frustrating
is it to have a top defense and i've
been there we had the worst offense in
the league and the number one defense in
the nfl when i was with the chargers
back in 1998 i think it was it's very
frustrating but defensively you have to
change your mindset and you completely
say we're going to forget about the
offense we're going to try to score
points we're going to get turnovers
we're going to give them field position
we're going to do whatever we have to do
to make sure we make their life easier
we can't depend on them to win the
football game we have to win a football
game and that's just a change of mindset
that's right and nobody wants to talk
about it but antonio brown now becomes
one of the most important pieces on
tampa and one of the most important
pieces coming back in the whole nfl
because if they didn't have him they
would be in a world of trouble who knows
how long mike evans gonna miss with the
hammy they have to have another wide
receiver on the outside probably scotty
miller before mike evans gets back it's
scottie miller and antonio brown
carrying that workload and then that
group of tight ends that they have
they're all gonna have to be actively
involved in the pass game i would think
right
i love mike evans love chris godwin
but antonio brown is their best wide
receiver
i agree antonio brown is their best wide
receiver because he can do it all he can
go deep he can catch 10 yard out routes
he can catch slant routes and split the
difference like odell and take it to the
house he's a hall of famer no question
about it he's he's fantastic man one of
the best that i've ever seen and the
thing is like when i watch receivers
it's hard to impress me
you know from a receiving standpoint i
played with randy moss who i just saw
his work ethic and things like that i
play
with and against and i just think that
antonio brown is one of those guys where
he's a pain in the butt off the field
but when he gets on the field he's just
totally locked in and that's the type of
guy that tom likes he trusts him he can
throw the ball up antonio's gonna go get
that football and you see why tom brady
is always fighting for him to be on that
roster right even even when coach aryans
doesn't want him it's moments exactly
like this and tom brady's lived enough
of these seasons to know the guys get
beat up before the playoffs and you have
to have depth specifically at the
position which are his playmakers and
he's kept a b for that reason
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports